les terrains synthétiques comme celui ci
il y en a plus de 12000 aux états unis
au québec on en compte plus de 225 pour
le soccer et des dizaines d'autres pour
le football leurs compositions et
quelques amis griffin entraîneur à
l'université de washington depuis 22 ans
cette petite baignoire ça va absorber
les chocs sur la surface sont en fait
des pneus recyclés et broyer environ 20
29 sont dispersés dans chaque terrain
les granulats volent dans tous les sens
au contact du ballon il se glisse
partout on en retrouve dans nos yeux
dans notre bouche et sono éraflures et
greffe une qui était aussi gardienne au
sein de l'équipe nationale américaine
elle est convaincue que l'exposition et
les contacts répétés aux pneus broyer
sont nocifs pour la santé
en 2009 elle a constaté que deux
gardiennes de la région de seattle avait
développé un cancer
ce n'était que le début elle s'est mise
à recenser d'autres cas de cancers parmi
les athlètes qui évoluent sur des gazons
artificiels sa liste non scientifique
contient aujourd'hui 253 cas dont 102
lymphome et 54 de leucémie parmi les
joueurs de soccer touché près de 60%
sont des gardiens
une donnée troublante sachant que les
gaz et représente à peine 10 % des
joueurs
pour l'entraîneur l'explication est
évidente les garder en plus souvent en
contact avec les granulats donc plus
vulnérable au connecticut
des chercheurs partage les inquiétudes
des migrants fine organisme scientifique
indépendant et analyser une vingtaine
d'études citées par l'industrie pour
prouver que le produit était sécuritaire
le rapport de l'organisme publié en 2007
relève notamment de nombreuses failles
dans les méthodologies utilisées
il recommande l'adoption d'un moratoire
sur la construction de nouveaux terrains
le chimiste gaboury benoît de
l'université yale a étudié la
composition des synthétiques adonnant de
ce groupe en extrapolant les résultats
de sa recherche
le professeur estime que les plus broyer
peuvent libérer une vingtaine d'agents
cancérigènes et tout autant de
composants irritant pour le système
respiratoire
[Musique]
les granulats qui est aussi ce
toxicologue de l'université yale
l'étude acquise
nos aînés avec ces études ont révélé la
présence de 300 produits chimiques dans
les plus bruyants mais quelle joie au
doj tadjeur exposito une charmante dame
de magasinage des fêtes viennent y
aurait fait que de multiples textes un
exposé mike shinoda docteur vassiliou
déplore aussi le manque d'études
épidémiologiques sur le sujet il compte
en compléter ou dans les prochains mois
en suivant un groupe d'athlètes exposé
au gazon artificiel
à montréal la direction de la santé
publique se fait rassurante
oui on peut quand même le risque selon
la toxicologue n'est pas significatif
elle recommande quand même de bien se
laver les mains après avoir été en
contact avec ces terrains oui on les
connaît les produits chimiques
oui en actions qui sont cancérigènes est
ce que on peut y être exposées et à
quelle dose qu'elle est l'absorption et
ensuite c'est quoi leur
si les doses elles sont trop petites
je vois
non si
le leader mondial du synthétique peters
n'a pas voulu accorder d'entrevue à la
caméra notre appel au sens social de
montréal a été transférée firme de
relations publiques basée à new york par
courriel fait auteurs affirment que son
produit a fait l'objet de plus d'une
centaine d'études qui n'ont pas
identifié de risque pour la santé
humaine
l'entreprise est confiante que les
recherches menées présentement par l'
agence américaine de protection de
l'environnement confirmeront ses
conclusions entre-temps à seattle
émigrée femme fait tout ce qu'elle peut
pour limiter les risques
ses joueuses ne peuvent quitter
l'entraînement sans prendre une douche
et sans mettre leurs vêtements
directement au lavage et par dessus tout
elle préfère une chose que son équipe
joue sur du dre gazon ici en train d air
et du canada montréal